playing hamlet has helped me ask
questions of myself that usually i
leave
buried deep inside
i never thought i'd do anything like
this
to be or not to be
that is the question
[Music]
put your hands on your belly
take a deep breath in
my name is leslie currier i'm the
founding managing director of marin
shakespeare company
the methodology of our program is
inspired by drama therapy
it
creates laughter in the room
and it breaks down barriers between
races and ages and
groups if you didn't ask that question i
wouldn't say for here lies the point
it's very beautiful work
and we've seen a lot of transformation
most of the men in the group don't have
any theater experience and haven't
studied shakespeare before so when we
start talking about the plays and the
characters
they're just bringing their own personal
life experience to the conversation
i still heal my broken wings when i
first came in i thought i would never
act again
i attended college back in nebraska in
1968 and 69 i was a
co-major theater and music
when i came into prison
there is this
certain demeanor that you have to
establish so in essence i'm acting on a
day-to-day basis just to survive
to be able to be up on that stage
letting the true
steve come through
but in the person of the character
that's the freedom i get and that's what
i hope comes out when i do polonius
pastoral historical common
this role is
is so challenging that it makes me go
through the entire gamut of emotions
he's so conflicted that
man i must have pulled from every facet
of my life
i've
been betrayed before i've had my trust
broken
i've
i've done really horrible things to
people
you know in a rage like hamlet's done
well you may see the inmost part of you
what will that do that will not murder
me
over the years i've learned that i have
to give back
that i also have to
own up and
look at what i did realistically i'm
hoping through other things that i do my
acting i can give something back to
society
i've been able to
use
all of my past experience and kind of
channel it into this character
i hope that playing my role helps the
other inmates here
feel like
they're part of the story this doesn't
just help me escape this helps them
escape too
it also helps me uh gain a lot of
empathy for you know what other people
are going through
it's uh tearing open old wounds to try
to embody this to bring the character
alive and bring other people within the
story
it's it's difficult
but it's also really cathartic
it helps
it helps me heal
in this cruel world
draw that breath in pain
to tell my story
the rest
silence
[Applause]
you